Theresa Mays been out defending her
checkers deal are you confident that
she's going to be able to unite the
conservative party behind that plan the
only thing to do is to back the prime
minister and give her the maximum
latitude and support you know we're into
the art of the possible here a Dibble is
not about one we think on the back of a
piece of paper is the best theoretical
one we want the deal is the one we can
get and Prime Minister is being
steadfast in practical in delivering the
result of the referendum but having to
wrestle with a small or almost
non-existent Paulo Torre majority people
who keep up and telling her what to do
while the main focus has to be all of us
in the United Way backing her to try and
get a deal with the EU which is in the
interest of the UK so what would you say
that to those people in the Conservative
Party who are not backing her as you
would say it and David Davis for example
writing in the FT saying that under this
plan the UK wouldn't be running its own
economy that if we can't determine our
own laws it wouldn't be a functioning
democracy I mean that is some pretty
scathing words there from the man who
was supposed to be in charge of brexit
well I think the first thing to
appreciate beyond the obvious complexity
of this if we deal and walk away and
supposedly upon two WTO rules that the
economic cost and pain is probably
likely be very severe I mean in the long
term we'll be able to get trade deals
and things like that which will act to
economic activity but if we don't have
access to our closest market and our
largest market that will set us
backwards both in terms of economic
performance but also terms are the very
practical things like just getting
lorries across the English Channel so we
have to give the Prime Minister maximum
support and I think that any of those
two think they can either you know
criticize a challenge or anything like
that must realise that they are playing
with fire and that they will end up
destroying themselves do you think they
could also end up destroying the
Conservative Party in a minute as well
and Theresa may warning
it could mean that jeremy corbyn's Prime
Minister I'd like to think that the
Conservative Party can never be
destroyed but it would certainly damage
it very very severely for possibly a
very long period and yes there is the
serious danger that if Jeremy caught in
her to be Prime Minister I think she
would face economic difficulty anyway
but if anyone thinks that in elected
politics achieve something they ought
just to stop and think what would happen
if Jeremy Corbyn were Prime Minister
compared to them stand as a Conservative
candidate and becoming a Conservative MP
to see certain things in the interest
the country Jeremy Corbyn would
represent the opposite of that so I urge
all my parliamentary colleagues to look
strategically the sort of moment of
history where in the broader political
agenda we believe in and of course the
practicality is getting a brexit deal
which is and must be in the long term
economic and political interests of the
country I've been listening to what
you're saying and it seems to me as if
you're not really telling people to get
behind this brexit plan because you
think it is a great future plan for this
country you're just saying look the
alternatives are either worse it's the
plan that we've got so you need to just
hold your noses and back it I mean
that's not exactly something that is
going to excite members of your party
who are hoping to take advantage of the
opportunities of Breck's that is it look
logical purity is not on offer in this
the real world of politics and our
negotiation with the EU
it is variably and inevitably going to
involve an element of compromise we've
got to look at what is going to work in
the interests of the country and that I
think is exactly what the Prime Minister
into their cabinet had checked
did and then in publishing the white
paper explaining what they want to see
to the people properly and in Parliament
so this is a negotiation and no
negotiation is a perfect process but
those just think we can somehow flip
back to
born the world by governing ourselves
and becoming sort of fantastically
prosperous need to understand that the
world is far more independent supply
chain etc and you cannot sacrifice those
things and do economically well and so
that's why we need a sensible agreement
with the EU so we've got to get stuck
into those negotiations and the best
interests country are served by getting
the agenda Prime Minister has published
get traction and grip in our
associations with the EU so that we can
deliver a workable process of departure
but retaining a process we can get that
we can fit economically now before you
go I want to talk to you about Donald
Trump because earlier this week on
Friday you said that his visit was so
far a success do you stop it Matt that's
exactly what I said and I was absolutely
right it was in terms of the
organization and everything and although
there was the Sun interview by the time
he gave the press conference in Becker's
with the prime minister he'd obviously
amend the emphasis of some of what he
was saying so yeah I was absolutely
right and I'm glad that we held it
together a calm way and showed proper
hospitality to the President of the
United States and I think that he
enjoyed his visit and I think there have
been some good political benefits you
know it was preceded by him going to
NATO and now we hear that French walls
and 2% on their defence like us so you
know behind the scenes and all the press
comment and the drama and the did he say
this and did he say that have been some
very important items on the agenda which
in turn will now lead in his meeting
with President Putin in Helsinki a Toro
on which I hope that discussions here in
the UK will have had a measure of seen
setting influence there will be people
listening to you who think that we
shouldn't offer proper hospitality as
you put it to the US president I mean
this is a man who has talked about
sexually assaulting women who was locked
children in cages who
talked about immigrants infesting the US
I mean did the Prime Minister raise any
of that with him well on the Marburg
round this morning she replied as a
feminist as she put it to saying that
her views have been made clear in the
past he is the President of the United
States and in the real world of politics
and international diplomacy it was the
proper thing to do and I think we did it
very well and I think we'll have
benefits which were work which will be
to the advantage of the people who elect
us and now one of the things that Donald
Trump said that perhaps wasn't entirely
helpful to Teresa may was that Boris
Johnson would make a good prime minister
as someone who's worked with him in the
foreign office do you agree with the
president we've got one prime minister
and we should stick with her otherwise I
think we will be in a very unstable
position I spent two years working with
Boris I thoroughly enjoyed it we had
very good working relationship I
realised quite early on there was only
room for one showman in the Foreign
Office and it was clearly not going to
be me so my mantra was very simple
what's a reason to Boris and Bernard
stay out of the news and do your job and
that's what I did and I had a very good
constructive and cordial working
relationship Boris I wonder if right now
that boss Johnson's I left the Foreign
Office there you may be the showman and
there now that he's vacated that role
and any chance do you think of the
number of letters going into the chair
of the 1922 committee hitting the target
that would mean that there was a vote of
no confidence in Theresa May anyone who
thinks they might write a letter it
needs to stop and think about the
effects eventually would be actually I
think she'll win any vote of confidence
hands down if ever it were to come but
the very fact that people think they
might do this
utterly destructive utterly unnecessary
and they should back hurt